on va retrouver Léna Volochine qui est à
Koursk c'est en Russie on n'est pas très
loin de la frontière avec l'Ukraine
bonjour Elena vous disiez il y a
quelques heures dans un direct pour
France 24 que des bombardiers russes
survoler la ville direction l'Ukraine
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
oui on entend toujours des bombardiers
ici à un cours à cours qu'il est il part
de l'aéroport militaire non loin alors
ce qui est assez impressionnant ici là
où je me trouve j'ai pu aller parler
avec avec des gens c'est cette espèce de
réalité parallèle qui qui a encore pris
de l'ampleur avec cette opération
militaire puisque la propagande aussi
c'est intensifié qui accompagne cette
opération et les Russes disent ce n'est
pas Vladimir Poutine qui a attaqué
l'Ukraine c'est l'Ukraine qui a attaqué
Vladimir Poutine Vladimir Poutine défend
les populations russophone nous devons
imposer le bien par la force voilà les
discours que j'entends ici de la part
des des passants alors Vladimir Poutine
vous le disiez à employer les termes de
d'opération militaire pour des
militariser pour des nazifier l'Ukraine
cette espèce de point d'orgue de
catharsis de cette année de conflit qui
avait lieu dans le don-basse ou
finalement depuis 2014 on entendait ici
dans cette partie du monde dans cette
partie russophone et également en
Ukraine ses discours russes ils n'ont
pas été entendus jusqu'en Occident on
n'a pas pris l'ampleur du phénomène et
de cette réalité parallèle qui était en
train de construire Vladimir Poutine et
voilà le résultat aujourd'hui une
invasion de l'Ukraine à grande ampleur
et toute une partie du monde de ce
côté-ci en Russie qui est absolument
persuadé que Vladimir Poutine fait le
bien alors attention il y a une brèche
néanmoins dans l'opinion on sent
vraiment une fébrilité d'abord il y a
beaucoup de gens qui refusent de parler
et les gens ici enrichissent savent
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de dire tout
ce qu'il pense par exemple à travers
toute la Russie en ce moment même il y a
des tentatives de manifestation même des
ce qu'on appelle ici des piquets
solitaires cette protestation solitaire
lorsqu'on tient une pancarte c'est la
seule forme de protestation non
autorisée autorisée soi-disant en Russie
mais néanmoins même ces personnes-là
sont arrêtées sont interrogés il y a
vraiment une une tentative de réprimer
cette espèce de de mouvement anti-guerre
ici en Russie et donc les gens qui
pensent qu'ils sont peut-être soit cette
opération ou bien pense qu'il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans ce
discours officiel de de dire que on
défend les populations russophone de
dire qu'on est en guerre contre les
nazis il y a sans doute des gens ici en
Russie qui n'y croient pas mais qui ne
le disent pas tout haut en tout cas le
danger aussi c'est que une fois envahi
l'Ukraine puisque c'est le scénario qui
se profile actuellement et bien Vladimir
Poutine a dit qu'il allait juger tous
les tous ceux qui étaient selon lui
coupable responsable des méfaits qu'il
leur reproche donc on peut vraiment
s'attendre à ce que cette atteinte à la
liberté d'expression qu'on voit en
Russie elle soit bien pire en Ukraine
puisque on sait que toute une grande
partie du pays est vraiment anti-putine
et vraiment
anti-rus même du fait que la Russie a
déclaré ce conflit non pas aujourd'hui
non pas cette nuit mais il y a déjà 7
ans en 2014 mais tout le monde
prétendait que c'était une guerre locale
de séparatiste on avait peur d'accuser
directement Vladimir Poutine et sauf les
Ukrainiens qui eux ont toujours martelé
que leur territoire était occupé c'est
ukrainien n'avait pas été entendu et ses
Ukrainiens risque gros aujourd'hui alors
que Vladimir Poutine va imposer sa loi
probablement en Ukraine merci beaucoup
Helena Volochine en direct de course en
Russie pour France